my guest tonight a very talented actor
who has
starred in the film shawn of the dead
star trek and the mission
impossible movies his latest tv series
truth seekers can be streamed on amazon
prime
video beginning tomorrow uh please
welcome i love this gentleman simon pegg
sir how are you i'm very good conan i
love you too it's nice to be back
it's been a while i think the last time
was the world's end when i was
drunk acting for you yeah uh we haven't
we haven't chatted in a while
certainly not since this pendant
and um i don't even know where to begin
i mean every interview that i do now
begins with how
are you how are you handling uh
this quarantine how are you doing yeah
um i'm all right i've actually
i enjoyed lockdown to be honest the
first part of lockdown you remember the
first wave it wasn't so bad
yes right um i was in blue side
i was fairly light i was isolated i was
at my house i was writing i was kind of
quite
i was nice to have an excuse when your
friend you know when usually you have to
pretend that you can't come out because
the kid's sick or the dog is in prison
or something
and i i was able to say no i can't come
out
there's a global pandemic and i wasn't
lying and i felt great about that
okay but here's the problem i did that
too and i like that
because i'm very anti-social and i like
to say i'd love to be there but there's
a pandemic can't make it
now i don't know if you're having this
problem i'm experiencing this
people that i never talk to that much
ever in my life
now say let's hook up on zoom and talk
and how do you get out of a zoom call
you can't they know you're home
these are people i was not close to now
constantly want to zoom
and catch up there must be a conspiracy
theory somewhere that states that the
people behind zoom
created covert 19 uh
to just one of the stock market killing
because
i'm the same every day there's there's a
zoom call to be that
you know i have to say i'm not the only
one i've been thinking you
of you a lot uh during this
uh quarantine during kovid because memes
like this
have been popping up constantly
um and like it or not
you are the face of uh
global pandemic and madness breaking out
how do you feel about that
i couldn't be more proud to be honest it
was something i'd always hoped would
happen
you know the funny thing is is that that
meme has popped up through various you
know through brexit and through
other uh you know the re-election of the
tory party whatever
has that that's cropped up at home a lot
and then as as the coronavirus uh began
to
sort of spread it it popped up again but
then
we passed the point when going to the
pub was actually allowed so the meme
itself became
outdated quite quickly when going the
winchester was no longer
advisable so um nick frost and i kind of
recreated that scene from sean of the
dead
i called him one morning i was on the
school run and i said nick i'm going to
send you some lines
we'll do the thing again but we'll make
it about staying at home
so that's on youtube somewhere that was
in the early stages of the pandemic when
celebrity videos were cool for the for
that two weeks when
they were yeah guess what i missed that
window so i've been shut out of any kind
of celebrity
there was a slight window and i screwed
up
simon i missed that window just if you
only got on the imagine
you know i'm curious because uh when you
first started out and you did sean of
the dead and i
i understand this because my people
uh are descended from uh ireland
i'm 100 irish so i understand what
is called in the uk the tall poppy
syndrome where
it's something that's in british culture
where if someone's had
a lot of success people feel the need to
chop him down
when you first hit with sean of the dead
um not long afterwards there were people
in the uk who had the sentiment
simon pegg's growing too big too fast is
that true
well i was i was aware that that might
so because sean was a was a
was a hit and and you know we we
received a certain amount of attention
i was anticipating this being the case
so um
in an interview i think with probably
the sun newspaper and they
and they accusingly said oh you're gonna
go off and go to hollywood now aren't
you like that's
some sort of treasonous criminal act you
know like i was gonna
cross some misty bridge at night and
never come home again
and i said quite i mean just
off the cuff i just said i'm not gonna
just leave and be in i don't know
mission impossible three
which was a film which didn't exist at
that time it was just mission impossible
too
and then about a month later jj abrams
called and said
hey do you want to be in mission
impossible three and i said yes i do
where's my plane ticket and uh
and that happened as well with what else
did it happen with there was another
thing that i
well probably star trek because i know
that you're a big si
i mean you've had this you you've had
this
run and i just because i've interviewed
you a bunch and i'm i'm familiar with
uh with your predilections
uh not all of them but you really do
i mean you idolized uh star trek and
then suddenly you're in
star trek it's just go ahead and
they're in space this is this is what it
was the idol in our sitcom space
which is where we sort of began there
was a line from my character about the i
the notion of certainty and the line was
as sure as eggs is eggs
as sure as every odd-numbered star trek
movie is [ __ ]
and then you jump forward like maybe 15
years and i'm writing star trek 13.
[Laughter]
it was a self-fulfilling prophecy i do
feel
i do feel that in a previous lifetime um
and not that you don't deserve success
because you certainly do
but in a previous lifetime you did
something very heroic
and wonderful because it feels to me
that you're constantly working on
projects or being able to join projects
that you would have been huge
a huge fan of you'd have been in line to
see that star trek
movie you'd have been in in line to see
mission impossible if you weren't in
them absolutely
it's true and it's very strange now it's
a lovely thing
and i've i'm never not blown away by
that sort of circularity of
the stuff that i enjoyed as a kid the
the you know
whether it be the films of spielberg who
i ended up working with or being into
something like star wars or star trek
and
and getting to participate in that it's
been a real treat you know and i'm here
now on the
you know we're making mission impossible
seven and uh we're not it's not called
that
i don't know what it's called yet but
it's certainly not mission impossible
seven sorry
um but we're here doing that and it's
very exciting
but behind you you can't see this but
lawyers are closing in on you
tom cruise is just like this with a gun
just yeah
just a little red dot on your head and
then down
uh you know curious
how you because this is a question
that i have for you is how do you do a
mission impossible movie you're on set
in italy i understand you guys are being
very careful
day to day-to-day do you know if you're
allowed to shoot
or if the protocols change how does that
realistically happen
well we're just we're just working very
carefully with the authorities here and
if they do change their protocols then
we pause
and we we reposition
and we you know we we're just being an
abundance of caution is the kind of
the buzz phrase here and that's what
we're doing and i think you know
when this happened in february nobody
knew what was happening
we have more knowledge now and more
ability to kind of mitigate some of the
problems that it throws up so we're just
being super careful
um you talk about being super careful
and i'm sure that you are
uh with with kovid but you're also
working with
tom cruise you're working with tom
cruise on a mission impossible movie and
you talk about well we're being very
careful
and i know anyone who looks at a
magazine has seen
photographs of some of the things that
we all know what he's done in the past
movies and we know that he likes to
notch it up
each time to the point where i don't
think it's possible he can notch it up
anymore
and now i'm i'm hearing about these
insane stunts that tom cruise is doing
uh on the set of this movie are you
present when he does those stunts
yes and for us it's like
i mean when you watch the movie and you
see him do those stunts and it's
nail-biting and there's a real sense of
of genuine kind of um peril because you
know that it's him
but you know he survived because he was
on good morning america that morning and
he did some press
when we do it when we watch him do it we
have no idea if he
if he's going to survive so he rides a
bike off a cliff and everyone's just
waiting for
good canopy good canopy anybody anybody
because tom cruise
it's terrifying it's terrifying are you
with him before
he gets on the bike and does does anyone
talk to him
uh and say like look it was nice knowing
you
you uh i'll pass on a message to anybody
you want to get to
yeah i mean he was hanging because he
loves it you know he puts in a lot of
work he trains rick i mean he literally
will become the best at you tell him
something he'll just become the best at
it and it'll take he'll take as many
hours as it takes
but he won't do the stunt until he knows
i mean the prep that went into the big
stance for this film are insane
but i yeah we saw him just before i
remember when we did the last one the
big helicopter chase
um was gonna we were in new zealand and
myself and rebecca ferguson we're gonna
go back to london and leave tom and
chris macquarie to do this big thing
and i said goodbye to tom and there was
a real kind of
then well good luck like not knowing if
if
he was going to survive the next 10 days
which were him piloting a helicopter
through these
you know these sort of glacial mountains
it was terrifying
yeah so uh you're there you're there
while it's happening and we all know
yeah like you say you see them on good
morning america which is
by the way that's how i determine if
someone's still alive every day
is i check good morning america
and if they're on it i know that they're
okay
you are are you a um you're an
adrenaline junkin a junkie aren't you
you're someone who likes to try things
yeah i mean i like you know snowboarding
and i like things that aren't
necessarily lethal i mean the stuff that
tom does that goes that's off the charts
that's not adrenaline that's some other
hormone you only secrete just before you
die
yeah i mean i'm i'm always happy to do
my own stunts in this fortunately i'm
the computer nerd you know i just
i'm basically his gps and i just tell
him go left go right jump off this cliff
yeah so i'm happy i'm happy there you
know yeah so the only thing that could
really go wrong
for you is you might delete some of your
files
that would be that's that's the yeah
that's what's going to happen to simon
pegg on one of these movies is
he pressed ctrl alt 7 accidentally
and someone had to step in and correct
it i might accidentally
reveal my history on my web browser and
oh no don't look at that
it's nothing nothing at all let me ask
you about truth seekers um
this i feel you're
i'm a huge fan of your work and i think
one of the things
that you specialize in if
uh if and see if you agree is you're
very good
at blending tension
with comedy you have a very good ear
for just how to get that mix it's a very
hard thing to do
um but i've loved that you've done it
the way you've done it in all your
movies and now
i believe that you're that's what you're
accomplishing with truth seekers is to
try and get a nice blend of
it's humor but it's also you feel like
the stakes are real
and there are moments of real horror is
that fair
did he lose me or did i lose him yeah
absolutely i mean
you froze completely on my end i think
it's the the our connection
yeah it was really funny on my end
because it looked like i just asked you
the stupidest question you've ever heard
because i i asked you this question i
thought was pretty decent and you just
stared at me for um like five minutes
and i thought wow i just dare you
diamonds really pissed at me for
complimenting his ability to blend
comedy with horror and tension
so if you're angry tell me now i no i
i'm
i'm glad you think so i mean really it's
about
not when you with something like horror
you just don't make fun of the horror
you keep the horror intact it's very
easy to send up
anything which is sort of genre-based
sci-fi horror it's easy to make fun of
it because it requires us to
to suspend our disbelief and if you just
fold your arms and go that's ridiculous
you can spoof it or make fun but if you
just kind of let the comedy happen
adjacent to the horror then you can have
your cake and eat it you know so that's
kind of our philosophy with true seekers
which is a
a sort of paranormal investigation
comedy it's nick's show really nick
frost is the
is is the main guy in it and i crop up
as his boss
um now and again but um yeah that's uh
that's our kind of always been our mo
really is
is don't don't take the easy route you
know
yeah well it's one of the things i
remember uh i we
re-watched i've watched hot fuzz several
times
uh with my son he's a massive fan of
yours and we've watched it several times
and
and one of the things that i really
marvel at is it's
so funny and the comedy is so well done
but the stakes are high and my heart is
racing the whole time because you don't
condescend to do the action as comedy
it's real action oh sure yeah absolutely
because otherwise it would be it
wouldn't work as well you know yes
and we love those movies we wouldn't we
weren't seeking to make fun of
of of the american action film it was an
absolute love letter to it so it would
be silly to
do anything but try and be one of those
things you know right
right uh nick frost i know that you guys
have been
friends forever this started with you
before either of you had made it
and long before sean of the dead in your
20s you guys were hanging out together
probably i mean what were you doing what
were the two of you doing
to entertain yourselves and and and
to sort of let your imaginations go well
we were sharing a flat together in north
london
and um we had very little
uh in the way of possessions we had a a
gas heater on top of which was a
combo television uh vhs
uh recorder and we would watch episodes
of the x-files
seasons one and two as it was then it
was about 95-96
and um and also on the weekends we go
ghost hunting which was our code really
for
sitting in my renault five and getting
blazed in the countryside
okay so your search for the paranormal
involved you and nick frost sitting in a
car
uh and doing some kind of recreational
drug
exactly and the paranormal thing was
seeing how many cheetos we could eat in
half an hour which would be
an unbelievable amount you know i are
normal levels of glutton
simon i suspect that many great ghosts
napoleon abraham lincoln uh queen
victoria
contacted you guys but you were too
stoned
[Laughter]
probably yeah yeah whatever yeah
whatever gandhi
whatever we're busy
we have a uh we have a clip here from
truth seekers
that we're going to show right now
anything we need to know to understand
this scene
i think this is um as as nick's boss in
the show i kind of
tasked them he's basically a satellite
repair engineer with a new partner
and um he's sort of running a ghost um
hunting
um um business out of the back of his
van
and i'm sending him off to various
places and i i know where i'm sending
him you know these are the kind of
places so this is me tasking
gus with um going to a haunted um
a formerly haunted hotel i think all
right let's take a look at this uh
clip from truth seekers listen can we
not have another day like yesterday
relax it's not like every place we go is
gonna be haunted
sorry did you say haunted i did yes
britain's most haunted
three-star hotel the portland beacon and
i thought that might uh pique your
interest gus it's nothing but a cheap
tourist drawer believe me i've
i've looked into it thorough as ever
that is why you are my number one
installer gus mia cooper
and you mister ah my number
28. nope not bad
and we're back you and i didn't actually
see the clip
they'll slice that in because wasn't it
good
yeah brilliant um
i i will get the word out on truth
seekers because uh as i've
as i've told you many times i'm a
massive fan of your work uh you're
uh enormously talented uh gentlemen and
i'm
very happy that these great things keep
happening for you you know god bless you
well it's
it's lovely to see you i i was um i was
talking to someone the other day about
uh it's been a while since we were
how's andy doing is he around what's
happening with him you know it's so
funny
he he's here uh he was here and we were
he was shooting with me
uh but um then he took off
i said look well i'm gonna go do some
interviews he's like well then i'm out
of here
he took off so enjoying the good life
somewhere if you can in quarantine it's
really focused us on our priorities this
pandemic that's for sure
yeah yeah uh all right well truth
seekers
truth seekers is available to stream on
amazon prime
video uh starting tomorrow and uh
whenever you and your good friend nick
frost do anything i'm down for it so i'm
very excited for this project
and uh thank you buddy thank you so much
for doing this what time is it where you
are by the way
it is just approaching 11 o'clock in the
evening here
okay and is the american election over
yet would be great if you were a couple
of days ahead of us and you could tell
us what happened
oh i do i know and it's it's incredible
you won't believe it
okay uh just finished my interview with
uh simon pegg the only man who knows
what happens uh next tuesday hey simon
thank you
spoilers don't worry no spoilers no
spoilers no spoiler
actually people would take a spoiler
alert on this one but um
thank you so much always a joy to talk
to you
and he's frozen again at the end you too
buddy you take care
simon they're really can you hear me it
really was a great moment where i asked
you a question and you just
you just stared at me and it but you're
frozen
but it really did look like you were
ricky gervais and i had said the wrong
thing
yes it can we'll talk about that over a
pint sometime
privately um so nice to talk to you sir
be well me too mate and good luck on
november third man the world is crossing
his fingers
yeah i i yeah i know i know it's
craziness i think
i think we'll be good i think we'll be
good okay all right about it i'm sorry
take care and see you sir okay bye